in this tutorial we are going to talk
about bias and fairness to think about
these issues when you're developing your
models when you are deploying our models
and this is really aimed to be really a
practical kind of presentation because I
often tend to feel like the general
presentations and the most calm
presentations about bias and fairness in
a I are very fluff
they really don't discuss really
practical beats and insights and this is
really about this really like um more
practical discussions and when I
submitted this tutorial back in the
proposal back in May I have this part of
ends on tutorial and after giving this
talk a few times I really realized based
on feedback from the audience is like
the tool is very straightforward and
easy to use what is really hard is to
understand and reasoning about results
that the tool gives so there is a
section kinda in the middle of the
tutorial where we'll go actually through
Jupiter notebook with some code and
examples but I will expect this to be
really straight for for you and you can
try out that the tool afterworld and you
can once again just message me and I
will help you with that but this is
really about discuss discussing what is
fairness when should we should care
about the bias our algorithmic
decision-making works and some kind of
case studies will actually show real
results of fairness audits so just the
typical about me when I submit the
tutorial I was in Chicago doing my
postdoc at the Center for data science
in pub
policy also together with data science
for social good summer fellowship I was
a technical mentor last year edition in
2018 but since then I moved to Lisbon
and I'm now in the industry but I'm
still working these issues I'm creating
a new research group the typical name is
either fat or faith I always selected to
the site so is fairness accountability
transparency and ethics in AI and just
to give you a little bit context about
the work that I develop in Chicago where
in which the the Akitas toolkit is part
of this work so I'm one of the main
contributors of the toolkit and the
Center for data science in public policy
and there is science for social good
they really aim to tackle real world
problems with data and machine learning
in the intersection of Public Policy
social good kind of projects and
problems from criminal justice workforce
development education healthcare these
are some of the partners that they are
the ones that provided us data you can
think about the center has kind of an
comes mini Consulting Group within the
university but for helping nonprofit and
government agencies and you can see here
the White House but just a disclaimer
this is White House before 2016 and we
have interesting projects that received
like really media attention like the
police projects I don't know if you
recall but there was some wave of in
adverse incidents between the police and
the african-american community in us and
what these projects aim to solve was to
predict the police officers that were at
risk because of stress levels because of
working too many hours of having an
adverse incident so we can adopt a
proactive approach of redirecting these
officers to psychological and counseling
and therapy and and this kind of a group
workshops this is just an one example
about the industry sort of small
overview pizza is a startup company that
basically works for FinTech and online
payments to detect froth and antimony
laundry so in the private sector when I
was deciding to to industry I was
considering either healthcare of FinTech
because they are really really similar
with this kind of predictive in a risk
assessment for decision making and here
we really aim to catch fraudsters while
not hurting or not allowing people to
know make online payments if they are
not really fraudsters and that's one of
the issues that we want to tackle and to
make sure that we have fair
decision-making so as I said before we
are really in the first part discussing
a rhythmic season making sources of bias
the finest definitions common
misconceptions in this area in the part
2 of the tutorial we'll go and deep dive
a little bit about the toolkit and
actual results and some additional
considerations so the idea is that at
the end of this tutorial
when you are in your company or in your
organization and you are developing
models for decision-making you can
really reason
what you should care what are the
consequences of the models that you are
developing Oh gets infected how to get
data and collect these results to give
the decision-makers or the product
managers or leadership on your
organization's to make more informed
decisions actually I want to ask you how
many of you are data scientist engineers
okay so it's really not about you to
make the decisions of what is fair not
fair
what should get it boil or not is really
about data science is to really
understand what's going on collect data
about what's going on and give the
decision making and decision makers
systematic menu of options because in
this area often people don't really
agree and what we really want to avoid
is to have this kind of a subjective
decision making where if you are working
with a given product manager or
leadership you make a given this agent
if you are working with other middle
management you have a different kind of
decision it's really about creating this
systematic kind of analysis about what's
going on and then someone will make the
decisions in our projects in Chicago in
with our partners it was actually the
organization that would take the model
that was really defining what they care
about what would be what should be the
impact if they care about hurting
specific groups or not not as data
scientists to really define that
so from you and most of you at the
scientist how many of you have worked in
decision-making and not text or image
classification but rather like
classification for scoring and really
okay so this initial part might be
trivial for you but because of
requirements were like
entry-level and let's go a little bit
dive on this so some examples of
algorithmic decision-making so for
operation and what you are really like
deciding and predicting is are you
getting a charge back from this
transaction was this credit card stolen
or not you're making a call on credit
lending is the classic example of
decision making insurance II an
insurance policy pricey nowadays is also
based on decision making up the risk of
your behaviors screening job candidates
and we can discuss some examples on this
out by the way there will be some
question PNA break points throughout the
presentation so not just at you
preventive health care it's really
interesting because now we are shifting
from reactive so people get a disease
and you want to get treatments to kind
of proactive and preventive health care
you are actually predicting the risk of
someone developing a disease and based
on these risk scores you really try to
avoid it but most these people
forgetting that in getting a better
outcome also in the criminal justice and
in the police
there has been especially in us the
adoption of this kind of already
decision-making so just to give you a
little bit more of a context this is an
example of a decision making project I
worked on and it's the newest of Chicago
and our partner was Justin County Kansas
and this is kind of project where you
really really face risks of being
unethical and it's really really
important to based on how you scope the
projects how you define interventions
and who is going to take the
interventions then the same machine
learning model can be used for good or
for evil
and here is an example of this is
actually a timeline of a real person and
that was living in Johnson County Kansas
and this was the first project where all
the public data from public services
in the county and got together in league
linked and we were able to really trace
all the interactions all the touch
points of the individuals with emergency
medical services I'm low on bookings
from the police all interactions with
the police officer get some kind of law
we had access to them mental health
consultation services public health
consultation and the goal here is to
tackle the problem of recidivism in
people with mental health issues so in
the u.s. access to mental health to
people at there that don't really have
health insurance is really tough so if
someone gets mental health break down
and they punch someone on the streets
they are running naked on the streets
they even in the case they called 911
and they say they want to hurt
themselves police goes along and goes to
the sides and often the what they do is
they arrest the people and the people
get a jail booked and as this kind of
obvious jail is not the right place for
people with facing a mental health
breakdown and Johnson County in Kansas
is really progressive on that and they
developed these corresponding program
where a mental health provider an expert
would go along with the police force
calls with specific codes like substance
abuse domestic battery suicide calls and
so on and and they try to stabilize the
the person and if possible to divert
them to the hospital hospital and not to
the jail but this is reality I notice
again I'm repeating myself of these
proactive versus reactive but you'll see
what I'm getting into with these
decision making and predictive kind of
with this project our goal was to base
on people so our cohort was people with
a mental health slightly indications of
mental health issues
since ever in our data that got a jail
booking in the last three years to
predict the risk of them getting a jail
booked in the next year so we can rank
people and we can offer access to mental
health service so mental health
providers who call people would go to
people houses and will ask people hours
life going if they need some help and if
they are receptive to the intervention
they would start and joining some kind
of preventive program and why there are
unethical or ethical risks in this
project because if we get this
prediction to the police they could
actually arrest people beforehand like
like kind of a Minority Report kind of
setting but thankfully the good news is
that the intervention is a mental health
intervention not pull the pull a police
intervention so the only part the only
organization that got access to the full
integrated data and the prediction was
mental health sense and not the police
not the court rooms just the mental
health providers and this is just to get
a little bit on the context on when we
move on to bias and fans the
implications of deploying specific
models versus others so in kind of a
nutshell algorithm decision-making can
be seen as statistical risk assessment
so you want to predict the likelihood of
an outcome and these outcome can be this
patient developing a given disease this
credit card being stolen the job
candidate actually like lead of the
shock and it being successful in the job
and usually this is solved using
critical training a binary classifier on
historic
cases and contrary to image
classification
multi-class classification where we
usually take the class that gets the
highest score here in the binary
classification we just get one score and
in order to really have control on what
you are deploying we don't use the
typical predict on 0.5 thresholding we
use the actual predict problem or
discourse if it's a probabilistic model
the the probability score if it's like a
3 based model just we rank examples by
the instance by score so here is an
example and a fake example of if we have
a sample with twenty instances and we
got we already trained our model and we
get the scores and we have the true
level so this can you can think about
this as a validation set or test set and
here we have a total of 6 positive
examples and 14 negative so our
prevalence or base rate or prior or
usually and call the the rate ratio
between positive examples and the total
and examples is 30% and let's assume
that we the model is the same the scores
are the same the ranks are the same we
are just now defining a way of testing
the model and the way we define how we
want to test a model we can can either
be based on a threshold or based on a
topic a capacity if you think about job
candidates you receive thousands of
resumes and you want to rank the top 100
candidates that can proceed on on the
next steps of interviewing process in
these situations this type of
predictive poems you have a capacity and
you define Chi and you always take the
top k examples if you think about like
even base decision-making like fraud or
if you have a specific event like
interaction with the police or you go
and see the doctor then we need to
define a threshold on our validation set
and we deploy this threshold on our test
set in production so if the score gets
above a given threshold then we consider
this as positive and this example we
have defined our threshold as 0.98 or
our K is 4 and we got right about all
the predictions so we have four ones in
the label column we have zero false
positives we have two false negatives
though there were two positive examples
instances that didn't get classified as
positive and we have 14 two negatives so
I don't know if you are familiar with
the ROC curve if you go to the Wikipedia
page of the ROC there is this table
there that essentially it's not present
in any other web page on an article on
on the Wikipedia but this is really
really useful because it really defines
the confusion matrix and all these
supervised error based metrics that we
typically calculate so it in order to
really understand the results that the
Akitas took it gives you you really if
you don't know these rates all these
rights is good if you have on the side
this table and can help you really
understand what what you get so as we
were there we define threshold on top k
equal 4 and now we can compute this
matrix
and the false positive rate we don't
have any false positives is zero the
recall we catch we caught four of out of
the six positive instances so it's
two-thirds the false negative rates is
like we have two we need two out of six
positives so it's one-third and our
precision because place on the predicted
positive set we got all correct
so our precision is one congratulations
but the thing is maybe you have capacity
to interview more than four candidates
so maybe you can just call the ribbet
down on the list to consider the
predicted positives and if we now have a
threshold of 0.92 or k equal ten the
story is a little bit different but once
again it's exactly the same model and
the same predictions but we get very
different results so now we have six
three positives for false sniper fault
for false positives and no false
negative so our recall is one as if we
can see we didn't miss any positive
example our false positive rate though
is not zero anymore because we have one
two three four false positives so we get
4 out of 14 negatives so 0.29 our false
negative right we are not missing anyone
so it's zero and the precision is 6 out
of 10 because out of the 10 positives
will be missed 1 2 3 4 so we just got
six through positives and about the RLC
space it's it's really important to
understand how this works so for the
same model in example 1 we are operating
in this point so we got zero false
positive rate and we got 2/3 on Rico for
the second example when you go to 10 we
already
got the max recall and our false
positive rate is 0.29
if we keep going down the list until we
consider everything as positive
we'll keep like along this axis because
we already caught all the positive
examples so recall cannot be higher than
1 and the false positive rate will go
until the max because you are
considering all the false positives as
positives now and it's also really
important to understand the the the
separation line here so the in this line
we get recall equal to false positive
right and why this is important because
if we define recall in a probabilistic
way it's a given that we have a set of
examples that the label is positive what
is probability of classifying given
instance of the positive examples as
positive and the false positive rate is
the same thing but now conditioned on
the negative examples so based on not
being positive label what is probability
of misclassifying the non positive as
positives and as you can see when these
two probabilities are equal basically we
are getting through with these
probabilities independent of the label
that's why we say this is random because
doesn't really matter the label the true
outcome of the examples the probability
of predicting as positive is the same
regardless of the label and this is also
very important because often people and
this is this misconception and and it's
not like because I didn't figure out or
it's just because based on practice
often in text classification or in image
classification we have a balanced
dataset for training and the base rate
the prevalence is 0.5 so we often say
it's like flipping the coin to get a
random prediction but when we don't have
balanced classes as it happens in
decision-making because what is common
decision-making is to have fewer
positive examples what really means to
be
is if your recall is equal to false
positive rate for any threshold that you
define so it can be a random for
specific threshold on 5 on 10 and 50
you'd get always on this line here is
the classifiers really random on the
positive predictions thankfully it is an
example it's far better than random any
question so far good but not all
instance are the same so now assume that
you have an attribute like skin color
and this analysis is independent of you
using this attribute for the model or
not and we will get there if you should
use these attributes on your models this
is now just doing the exactly same
analysis but now you have two subgroups
what first is non-white and you can
count do the same exercise for non-white
how many level positives we have 3 so 1
2 3 how many level negatives we have 6
which is 1 2 3 4 5 sorry how many level
negatives the zeros for I mean non-white
sorry
1 2 3 4 5 6 and the group size is 9 and
the prevalence of this group is 1/3 for
the white we do the same thing we also
have three level positives so one two
three level negatives we have 8 1 2 and
then 4 6 8 group size is 11 and the
prevalence is 0 27 and this is really
important to keep in mind that we
actually have more examples from a given
group than the other and the prevalence
is higher on the smaller group though
so if we use the same threshold for
making positive decisions now we can
calculate semantics again and now you
see that the recall is the same the
precision is the same the false negative
rate is the same so because for negative
rate is 1 minus recall and the false
positive rate though is different in
0.25 on white the larger group and with
lower prevalence and is 0.33 on
non-white so if we think out the
probabilities so given that you are from
the group non-white and skin color and
the label is 0 the probability of make
of having a false positive is higher for
non white and white so now any question
about this subgroup decomposition
straight for so what about this question
this is these previous difference and
false positive rate between white and on
white a problem anyone can change an
answer take the risk
a actual yes that's also a very good
point but let's assume this is an
example but this is a very good point
and we'll get there as well so it really
depends so as you were saying wrongly
accused it really depends on the
intervention in the context if you're
providing help and benefits if you don't
need the benefit in you get the benefit
that's really there is a cost
opportunity because often we have
limited budget and we are spending money
on people and actually don't need a help
for a specific health care or education
but if you think about the the people
that get interventions it's it's really
not really bad to get an intervention if
you don't need it but if intervention is
punitive like being accused in criminal
justice or something like that then the
story is very different and we'll get
there so decision making is about
predictions and often the real I can say
it is like unless you have a really
limited capacity in your operating
really on the top there will always be
errors and bias is about in this context
this is not about statistical bias when
you are learning and machine learn if
you have a current machine learning bias
in this context is use is to define if
there are disparate errors across
different specific subgroups and
decision-making has been around for
thousands of years and this is often
interesting also in the generic and
common talks about fairness it seems
like oh we are smart and we have all
these knowledge and power and we know
how to use these tools and we are
building deep learning models and we are
changing the world we are so powerful we
need to be really cautious about impact
of what we are doing
but bias in decision-making has been
around for thousands of years like if
you read Plateau and the Republic and
you think about ethics all the policy
decisions have been around and every
policy decision will get some people
that will get more benefit or some
people will get more help so it's really
about the scale we are now in a in a
time of auto machine learning at oml
metal learning kubernetes deployment
everything is getting automated and
because we often just care about the
overall performance metric that our
client is fine or that we define that we
want to solve an issue and we define our
global metric as precision or recall or
f1 or whatever by the way a UC doesn't
make any sense incision Mickey because
it's not the same to operating on top
for top ten so a UC gives you the the
kind of a proxy of the overall
performance along all these thresholds
but in practice decision making you
operationalize in a specific trash so
it's really about precision recall and
not so much about the UC so you often
maximize your performance for this
global metric and you have some
heuristics or something with some
rancors and let's see even if we have
some kind of a fancy pepper I'm hyper
parameter optimization in place we just
pick the models that optimize our global
performance so the best get selected and
often we don't understand that two
models with same performance cool a
global performance might have very
different differences in this parade
errors across these groups so when we
are scaling and automating this
decision-making process we are not
really understanding the impact of the
model self in the in the system and
often we also have if we have automatic
decision-making as well if not have any
human reviewing and getting the
prediction we are creating feedback
loops in which we
I bailed to someone and people stay in
jail and we don't actually get the true
label if the people be released dude
they recidivate if we allow this
transaction to go would it get like
charge back was it really fraud we are
automatically declined the problem of
reject inference so we are creating all
these feedback loops and all these
automation and so on and we really don't
understand the impact and I really talk
with people from software engineers data
science to product managers the end when
I really come to or do you really know
what is impact in production of your
systems people often divert and change
subject or talk about other things yes
maybe I'm getting too boring but the
thing is really about understanding the
impact so there are many sources of bias
and the first are very obvious like the
world and the people is really biased we
are really biased and that's the way it
is and values are very different in
Germany in us in Chile in China and
Japan in Fiji values really are very
tied with culture and societal in
societies in general so different in
different regions of the globe bias will
be different and about the data when we
are developing these models we need
historical data and we just to recover
thing there are two types of bias in the
data the sample and the label let's just
focus first on the sample often we are
developing our machine learning models
in a sample of the population that is
different from the target population
that will get the decisions so imagine
that there are new types of candidates
new types of jobs that the companies
create and maybe 10 years ago there was
no product manager or maybe there was
but there was no machine learning
or there was noted engineer and now we
have so but we have all these models the
models created on this is all this
historical data and this is really one
source of bias that and often this is
also very dependent on time
so because the behavior is shifting and
we have all these feedback loops is
there is already like machine learning
model in production the the sample is
really is really a problem here and
people in social sciences and people in
surveys analogy they have deal dealt
with a sample buyers in a long time they
try to extrapolate given uh example the
polls political polls for all the
country for uses but in our case machine
learning we really need to use all the
data as much data as possible to really
capture the signal so this is one of the
sources of bias that we have another one
is the label and based on my experience
this is the most troublesome source of
bias besides where when people but I
think is too early for us to try to
change the world in people for now but
the labels are really a problem because
we often taken for granted that the
label is really true it's I got this
dataset and the label is one so are you
really sure that the level should be
worn is there really no noise in your
labels and if there is noise is really
random or it specific for some subgroups
there is all these area of control
factor fairness and I really advise you
to search and read some papers about it
but it's really interesting to think
about you know causal kind of methods to
try to figure out what if the label was
different what would the model really
learn a different decision boundary or
not and also their result when we think
about health care job candidates and
then we were saying like let's predict a
likelihood of the candidate being
successful how do we measure success
it's really once again our founder is an
holistic oh if he got promoted in the
first two years of the job and are you
sure that being promoted doesn't
introduce any any any noise it's not
conditioned on the managers in the
relationships not conditioned on gender
ethnicity background education political
views are you really sure about that so
this is really really really issue and
we should all think about it an example
in the u.s. is the police investigations
often really like as some kind of
political kind of drive on that so level
is really one of them of the issues and
you can even think of for instance in
fraud prevention we often get the
analyst to make the last call so it's
really an analyst figuring out if it's
rather not and it's really really hard
to to make a call for it and then we
came here we come here
if you guys want somewhere you can get
every step of the machine learning
pipeline in every step we are making a
decision which how we get data are we
aggregate data we store in linked data
you recall the example of the project of
Johnson cans County in Kansas where we
like linking data from different places
in us there is no actually national ID
card so we use like Social Security
number first name last night but often
data from interaction with the police in
9-1-1 you get errors and typos and so on
so record linkage is a huge source of
bias because you are introducing bias
into damage so you are in systemize and
rose because you are propagating the the
see the the the population
the subgroup size because you have
duplicates and the real size of the
group is not the one that you get
because instead of being in one person
you are continuous too and also on the
features on the attributes level that is
also bias because before there was some
behavior that you were capturing that
was divided between two people but their
actual the behavior should be aggravated
in just one person so you are actually
introducing buyers as well and on the
feature level the models you choose I
per parameters the metric that you
define to test just that you can also
introduce use of bias because you are
often selecting X number of models based
on that metric the way you deploy our
intervention is going to be used the way
you teach people to use the model the
way you maintain are you often really
retraining or not and do you really care
if the data if there is any kind of
concept drift the way you communicate to
the people out to use interventions or
not everything is introducing as
specific paths and at the end there is
also the action or intervention bias
because the information might be mental
health outreach as were saying or
specific nutrition consultation or some
training workout wherever and not all
the groups will be prone to accept
intervention in same way and not all the
groups in the intervention will be as
effective if we think about disease and
you have just one intervention it might
have different effects on older people
and younger people might have a
different effect on male versus female
so if you just if you just define one
set of intervention or even a couple of
in of interventions the way the Agena t
effect might might exist and also there
is a human that can override the model
recommendation and there's also a source
supplies any question so as I say in the
beginning often we got these discussions
of what it needs to be fair and as as
you know we are really responsible for
data-driven decision making they're
data-driven analysis we should not get
caught on this trap so there is really
no new virtual lis accepted definition
of what it means to be fair and it
really means on the innovation and I'm
going to give an example actually I have
two examples but I'm going to skip
second one and it's rather long so let's
think about people got to jail booking
and they go to pretrial and we have
predictive risk assessment of them being
of I risk of recidivating of getting a
jail booking next year and often that's
the proxy problem that we try to fit in
order to decide the bail amount that
someone should get or even don't get a
bail at all and this is keep in jail and
let's consider this example just release
or not giving a bail to someone so
different people might consider it is
fair if the model makes mistakes about
the name bail to an equal number of
white and non-white so absolute numbers
regardless of how many people got
arrested regardless of how many people
there is in the city in the states in
the country in the world some people
might say we should make errors in equal
numbers to the two groups this is one
definition and here C is a constant so
what really matter is that without of
the group you get the same contest it's
this is just one definition another
definition would be that
the chances that a given why turn on one
person will be wrongly denied bail is
equal regardless of the race this is not
looking at the labels this is just
looking to the attributes valleys so we
have two groups the probability of
making false positives is the same for
two groups and this can be defined based
on the population size in the city for
instance and this is one definition
another one is the one - precision so is
this is often thought as kind of a score
calibration so it's among the jail
population so the people had got
positive predictions so you remember the
threshold the ones that get above the
threshold among all that population the
probability of having been wrongly
denied so the profit of any false
positives conditioned on being in a
denied bail is independent of the other
skin code so this is the occult forces
coming right and once again this is the
composition because force is copyright
is one - position is from the political
positives how many false positives eke
and personally the ones I find more
interesting is reasoning about this one
so among the decisions that you have of
keeping people in jail how many you you
were wrong for the two groups - this one
that is conditioned on the label so
given that you actually are innocent and
you should not be in jail and you are
first from a specific group what is the
probability of innocent people from the
white group or innocent people from the
non-white group to get a false positive
and keep arrest and as I said there are
very different definitions there are
more like demographic parity and Sun I
will go over that in later on but just
you to really be mindful that we are in
the same set of context of punitive
examples and we already constrained
ourselves to just punitive
interventions and we have at least four
different and even if you don't agree
with even one let's say like two
different metrics that are often
competing against each other and you
often don't you can not guarantee both
at some times and perhaps any question
so I also have the same example but now
for the assistive and exactly the same
reasoning so but the the metrics on the
other side and I will really go this is
more for archive and you get on the
slides so it's same thing but nothing
about false negatives thinking about the
probability of missing people based on
the group size probability of missing
people based on the negative predictions
so people below the threshold what is
the probability of being from one group
or another and the label being positive
so you're not getting an intervention
you were cause you're not a good
candidate for the job and the false
negative rate is conditioned on you
actually being a good candidate for a
job but you didn't get selected what is
the probability once again is same kind
of reasoning many different metrics
often the way we are measuring fairness
is based on parity so we compare it's
one of these metrics that I just
mentioned between two groups so we
compare false positive rate of Group A
and Group B and we see the ratio and
this is really an interesting metric our
way of calculating because it allows you
to communicate like simpler so if you
tell to a non-technical person it you
are making three times more mistakes for
innocent people that are non-white and
white is easier to communicate then you
your false positive rate is 0.85 versus
0.77 this is really important not just
communicate in a clear way this is a
parity measure useful and fairness is
normative so it's about taking these
disparities and really define boundaries
and this is often our arbitrary
boundaries this the machine learning
community is adopting the
is kind of metrics from the Criminal
Justice cases on fair lending Equal
Opportunity Act where there were some
historical cases where the jury decided
that there was discrimination if the
benefit was lower than 80 percent of the
majority and this is really arbiter
really fine
eighty percent is if it's before a lower
than eighty percent it's fine I don't
know if it's fun or not but this is just
for you to get a notion that when you
are creating these kind of systems for
analysis
to define and you can go and see and
often it's very hard to get really cool
numbers also because of statistical
significance but it's important to keep
in mind that these thresholds are rather
I returned and here is like a summary
that we created to help our
non-technical partners to reasoning
about all these metrics so the way to
navigate this is asking the question do
you want to be fair based on disparate
representation or disparate errors of
your system so you care about false
positives or false negatives or you
don't care just care about who gets the
intervention and the action regardless
of the labels and if you don't care
about labels and errors then there are
many possibilities two examples here are
just equal numbers so you select the
same numbers for a group and for another
for intervention intervention meaning
getting accepted in the university or
passing to next run of interviews in the
in the job market or demographic parity
in the muriatic parity here means that
based on some definition of a population
and the population can be once again the
city the country the state if there are
sixty percent from group a and 40
percent of Group B you pick four
interventions
60% of interventions are for copay and
40% would be and this is a movie party
if you care about errors then it comes
the really tricky question do you really
trust a level if you don't trust the
labels just try contractor firms and see
if you get interesting results and often
you get exactly the same vector the
input vector and the label is different
and those are kind of obvious candidates
so far being suspicious but often you
can think about or if there is an
attribute that is not correlated in a
specific group to the outcome and the
other group is correlated and let's just
skip that attribute like H and see if
this input vectors are the same
besides these attributes and then is the
label really different it's just the
attribute any change in the label and
then you can figure out those those kind
of control file facto fairness
approaches but let's assume it works the
levels and then is really the question
are your intervention punitive or
assistive it's very punitive this is
just a list of metrics I talked before
if their assistive these are the and
this is really about narrowing down the
scope so I really strongly advised to
not look to this matrix if you are
providing a punitive intervention
because this is just will just distract
you from what really what is really
making a difference on your models and
the impact is really like the false
positives the false negatives is really
doesn't really people ant that hurt
because they got released but there are
some tricky situations which is the
intervention the people affected by
intervention might have two distinct
groups so if you think about child
welfare cases
I've run some audits on models like this
like using social workers to respect
homeless homes of people that are at
high risk of having some kind of a
adverse incident with the with children
like views or much mistreatment of
children and then the risk of being a
false positive is really high for the
families because you actually you are
good parents and social services are
coming to our house and trying to
inspect your home and how you behave
with your children so it's really
punitive intervention for the parents
but if you are assuring of your a child
and you are suffering some kind of abuse
then you really care about false
negative so you are really missing
children there are at risk and they are
not being considered by them so often it
really must again it depends on the
context and duplication but if you have
these different groups that can affected
form from the same decision then you
should care about the two sides of the
of the matrix but if not I advise to
just focus on one leaf and not the other
any question anything about the society
yeah it really depends on on the context
and if we can think about first health
care if the if the treatment has some
kind of side effects then you have the
both sides but if the treatment just the
tradition calls for the consultation or
active lifestyle then is good for
everyone and there is really no risk on
on being punitive on really
redirecting people to to good practices
but this is really about the menu of
options so at the end as I say incision
making it's been around for many many
years so at the end is a policy decision
and the people the companies the
organizations that are carrying on
interventions they should have a clear
picture of what are the target
population they really care about and
once again is not us that we should make
the decision but if we think about the
fraud prevention cases for instance you
might think at first that oh I just care
about false positives because my
transaction was declined and I'm a cadet
car was not stolen but if you think
about protecting people's that get the
card stolen and you should block it as
soon as possible then you really care
about false negatives so yeah it's it's
really about the menu and now for the
bank's care about which one of the banks
the banks should care about protect
customers that get tonight's car stolen
or to not kind of create friction on
transactions and not a little benign
transactions that are okay yeah no
explain it is not to make the decision
yeah that's actually with the enterance
this question which is really good
question because a question about all
the reform people and now we get this
more transparent is about using these
toolkits like Akitas and giving training
like this one and creating reports where
we really inform people about what's
going on and how that can affect
different people helping people define
always affected by the intervention what
are the specific groups you care about
and it's really about making this kind
of
processes and and practices that that
will help people making money pharmacy
so this is really the goal of the
tutorial is that you go out and you
follow up on these and you make really
inform people about what's going on just
a quick overview about this is more on
the research side so it's like the main
research problems in this in this area
is detection how can we measure and this
is about the Phoenicians and so on and
so forth like I don't know if you are
aware like these very famous people of
equality of opportunity that is about
parity and recall and there are many
papers on on definitions of like
sufficiency and so on another issue is
tracing the sources of bias so really go
back and see was this decision about
imputation about record linkage that
will introduce the bias how do we really
isolate where are drily sources of the
bias and the third problem is mitigation
out can we six and and try to mitigate
the risks and regarding the the research
panorama there are lots of papers on
detection and mitigation this is really
common machine learning computer science
people they really love optimization
problems so they define fairness
atomization problem they had some
regularization parameter and voila what
happens is that in real life in practice
you often cannot play around with
thresholds you cannot play around with
capacity you have fixed budgets you can
have all you cannot increase the
positive cases it really depends and
another really really easy issue is in
these examples because it's easy to
communicate we are talking about binary
groups so white versus non white male
versus female but in practice you I've
helped with the problems in us where the
ethnicity column have like
cardinality of 13 or 15 how can we
accumulate all these specific groups
together and the research work is really
theoretical on that and we start at 10
later but I think I should go faster
famous misconceptions is that shall I
use race or gender in my models if the
model doesn't see it
how can it be fair bias based on that
well this is the most common
misconception in this area because often
other features of some those features
those attitudes like in the u.s. social
economic background education the age of
the first jail booking is highly
correlated with your ethnicity really
really I correlated so it's really easy
to mean for one based on the others same
thing with the browsing history or
Instagram likes it's somehow easier to
detect if you are men or not based on
your interests so you really will not
fix it by just remove it and in same in
same time there might be the other way
around this that attribute might serve
seem features that you actually are not
able to measure but you can use that
attribute as a correlation of another
signals that are really important so if
the these activities correlated with the
label you should include that attribute
in your models because it will help you
make overall better decisions but then
is really about you then defining how to
operationalize and how to compare
different models another one is like if
you just follow the more graphic parity
you get fair outcomes this is not true
because this is not conditioned on label
so actually what you are doing is like
you're pushing to the top examples that
are negative the label is zero and
you're pushing to the top and then
basically you are crippling or your
overall performance this is not about
forgetting the overall performance no
overall performance is still the main
goal you actually I want to help people
you want to get good interventions but
then the secondary goal would be I
really care about the biases and the
fairness of of of my mouse
this is like a corollary there's lots of
papers about it it's really easy to get
to these just using to the definite
using definitions of false positive
right through negative right you get to
know that if the prevalence of the two
groups are different then it's
impossible to have FBR and recall and
precision parity at the same time and
this is like a corollary it's it's you
can you can research on these so what do
we know we know as a mitigation plan
nowadays you have two options if you
don't agree with the results or you need
to improve the results you can work with
try different approaches in your
pipeline you use one of these methods of
fairness based optimization you try to
use it for a specific problem and you
see if the results improve or you get
budget and you change the way you deploy
the models and you define different
thresholds and maybe if you get more
capacity doing three instead of
interviewing other candidates for the
job if you can interview 200 maybe you
get equal error rates across different
groups and this is really like at the
end you see even to solve these issues
money might might be the solution so
what is missing tools is missing case
studies very understanding
if these kind of patterns about fairness
and buy is really hold on different
geographies in different types of
interventions in different different
types of policy areas from healthcare to
criminal justice are are we really
getting common kind of results across
these groups is record linkage really
one source of the bomb is the label
noise so we really Raleigh's we are not
really sure of what is the panorama
regulation will come you might be sure
of that GDP are is just a start and is
they start tackling privacy in their
ownership but accountability
expendability
fairness there is a regulation that that
is coming and it's good and we also need
a review board so external entities like
SCA for food or for drugs we need some
kind of external boards for algorithms
and not algorithms for models and how to
deploy them and how to assess impact
continuously not just the specific
sample but also through time we need to
convert regular audits of the models so
out of it
is the first step towards mitigation
this is really the old-school cliche but
if you cannot measure it you cannot
improve it this is really really a
cliche but that's true and people didn't
choose to measure it so that's why we
develop Akitas and when it was released
was the first toolkit that would allow
you to for decision-making policy to
really get all its four species
different subgroups on binary
classification and now there are other
tools out there most of them really
focus on the mitigation side not much on
really understanding and the
understanding the metrics and tailor
what medications you should care about
we are also targeting and non-technical
people like public policy people like
management as well not just machine many
people or data science people and today
there are the toolkits out there the way
we vision Akitas is to be used when you
are evaluating in selecting models if
you are the scientist and if you're a
policy maker or a product manager or a
client that it's getting a model that
was outsourced to a consulting company
you should all eat the model before you
accept it to deploy and also you should
conduct regular audits of our models to
maintain the models as people often try
to get concept we try to get and see if
a small degradation we should really
start getting this as a standard
practice of actually actually see if
there is a regulation under cernan's
goals how can you use it it's a way by
the tool for non-technical people you
just you can install it locally and is
local web site where people can upload a
CSV with predictions and they can click
and get the results of the buyers report
there is the Python library which is
just use on your notebooks or wherever
just import and you see annual it's a
specific model and there is also the CLI
which is good for batch like you want to
all it like a thousand models that you
train and you just if you have the
predictions and the attributes on a
sickle table you just write down the
sequel query and it in travail
interfaces with your database and you
fetch the predictions and also uploads
the results for all these 1000 or 2000
months what do you need twelve it's a
model you need a prediction and you need
is finite a K or a threshold to create
this binarization you need the
attributes that you want to add it for
and once again these attributes might
are not been used on the modeling side
and you need labels if you are
interested in the disparate errors so
what are the weaknesses of a kit is the
most obvious are that we assume random
level noise so we assume the levels are
the true outcome of the past events and
we really treat them equally regardless
of the group and also its sample
specific but this is not a weakness of
Akitas itself is a weakness of the this
paradigm of auditing and by using
fairness because we need to create the
confusion matrix on a given sample the
size of the of the groups depends on the
sample maybe not all the patients or all
the people interacting looking no
justice systems or your your whatever
product you have in a given week or in a
given month or in a given year the
population and the suppose might might
be different the sizes might be
different the prevalence and the base
rates might be different and if we are
really measuring in specific samples the
the outlet for buyers in fairness is
bias itself to the
but for now this really unsolved issue
moves few other years it's creating some
kind of a community of kind of Alateen
through time or just continuous sliding
windows but just be mindful of the
results you get it's just based on the
sample you test so what you need to
define before accepting or rejecting a
model to go to deployment assuming that
your organization has evolved to really
don't accept a model to production if it
doesn't meet fairness criteria you need
to define what groups you care about in
the legislation in the u.s. there are
there is definition of what is a
protected group usually is based on race
ethnicity and nationality religion
veteran status sexual orientation age
but you might define a different type of
attribute to care about for your for
your situation and you need to define
what metrics concerns you care about you
need to define this so we started 10
minutes later
so I'd say more 10 to 15 starting 11:30
yeah okay so okay so before the paradigm
is before you pick if you just care
about level performance you pick maybe
the yellow model nobody actually does
these kind of pots but this is for you
to really get an idea
but as you all did for bison fans you
will unfold a new dimension and maybe
instead of picking the yellow model you
might pick a model that compromises the
global performance a little bit but this
is some kind of a lower bias so this is
really the paradigm for a model
selection this is an example of
comm-pass I believe most of you have
heard of these so there is a composite
notebook and let's go there and you can
find the case studies on the slides I
think will not have time for that
unfortunately so if you go to Iquitos
and after you install it varies these
and mo notebook and if you want to find
the data is on the examples and you have
the raw data with the scores and you
have the data that we use for the
notebook so basically this is actually
the data that was used to do compounds
article and ProPublica and you have the
entity ID if you have to score you have
the label value you have raised sex in
each category
Keita's needs categorical variables if
the input is non categorical it will
create automatic bins unless you define
what bins make sense and I think the
bins should be predefined by you in your
specific application because just
following this the distribution might
not be meaningful and basically this is
an example of using a kitten's on as you
Peter not book it's based on four major
classes group is very important group is
about just calculating the confusion
matrix for specific subgroups has been
really beginning example I showed biases
about the parity measures and you need
to define what is the reference group
you care about you might define the
reference group based on specific
predefined groups like you know men as
historical favorite or white people or
you can use the majority group so the
group that is the logic group will be
the reference
or you can use the mean metric group so
the group that for specific metric gets
a lower value and then you'll get the
reference so this disparity will be
bounded between one which is for the
minimum to plus infinitive the disparity
is always compared with the minimum
value and fairness is based on
thresholds you care about and will tell
you like this fair not fair and the
plotting is just we are not actually
data visualization engineers if there is
any here we are open to get contributors
so the charts are not amazing so you can
go throughout this but the group it just
made them the first main method is just
to we get all these predictions let's
just create a cross trap crossed up
where we group by the attribute for each
attribute and we calculate false
positives false negatives negatives and
and true positives and then you get
something like this now you are
aggregating by the attributes and you
get how many were predicted positives
and blah blah the number of level
positives or negatives to group size and
the total entities of the whole dataset
then you have the matrix recall through
negative rate false emission rate first
cover it
do you remember that table of metrics
all through ROC so they are here and
then you can plot it by the way this
helper and here we are showing the
number the size of the group and the the
coloring is really based on the size of
the group and the this is just specific
metric value this is for false negative
right for instance you can plot all
matrix at the same time you can
basically here you define just the
number of columns you want then here you
are calculating the bias and you get the
disparity based on predefined groups
where you pass dictionary with the
predefined groups you care for two
attributes will be the denominators and
then you just pass the cross that you
got the original little frame for
statistical significance calculation so
basically what we are doing here is
based on the metrics for a systematic
cares about false positives we get all
the false positives for specific group
possibilities for another group like
just binary and we calculate the the the
duty tests for this and this is a simple
in the disparities and then you can plot
the disparities here in three maps is
the size is the size of the group and
the color is the darkest is the larger
disparity the lighter is lower disparity
so the this guy is if you see here the
the groups are always the same size but
based on the metric they might have IR
or lower higher or lower disparities so
yeah I think I need to wrap up I'm sorry
for this we started later because people
were coming in but it seems we need to
go any question and reach out to me on
LinkedIn or so and you can ask questions
based on the slides there is more things
there but well
yeah here you can see this is actually
the data from compass and you can see
like one of the things that people were
complaining was the false positive rate
of african-american being twice as a
false positive rate of Caucasian so this
was actually part of the article and the
to detect this for the women versus men
thing it yeah so one of the
misconceptions in these areas like it
seems like his AI that is creating bias
no he is is actually showing the bias of
the historical tests so this is the
misconception so depending on the
metrics one Matic City they figure out
was like just the selection parity so we
were selecting much more males and
females regardless of the label so if
you really care about the label people
are actually deserved to be selected the
predictions were basically kind of
independent on that and but also based
on the just base rates of historical
data they found that the base rate for
men were much higher on success than
than women so yeah just this is about
using these kind of tools to really
assess what's going on on your test data
and do it regularly
this actually there is a bit on that on
the on the end of the presentation is
about you can override and put in place
unfair I'm wrapping up unfair unfair
interventions and fair decisions in
order to override this Torico case so
you might decide to actually be unfair
and start selecting our
some kind of affirmative action there is
an example but for the historical
unfavored so you are changing the way
you are collecting data to favor things
sorry guys I'm really sorry
[Applause]